debenhams boots monsoon new look HMV M&S
BHS Carphone Warehouse carpet right
House of Fraser toys-r-us home base and
pan wells what do all of those brands
have in common they have all closed
retail stores and in some cases have
closed full stop last year a record five
thousand eight hundred and eighty-three
shops closed their doors in the UK and
it doesn't look like 2019 will be much
better the fact is the way we shop and
consume has changed massively and unless
we take radical action our high streets
will only continue to decline house
therefore interested this week when I
heard that Amazon they're opening their
first-ever clicks and mortar stores in
10 UK locations
there'll be pop-up shops that open
customers new content new brands and new
experiences and ladies and gentlemen
that is the future want to broaden this
out if I can be sure because there's
something very strange going on with
employment in this country because we
hear from the government we have the
lowest unemployment since 1974 at 3.8
percent and economists all agree that
actually an economy the size of the UK
you'll never get it any better than that
and yet we're speaking on a day where
1800 people might have lost their job
with insurance for him there's possibly
about 1200 we'll go from an engine
building plant in Wales and Philip
Green's restructuring of the Arcadia
group so you might be adding Burton top
man Dorothy Perkins in one week's time
when 18,000 people who work in retail
and I've not even gone to the Associated
industry so they could buy so what I
find developed about so I will come back
to women
we're here from the government we've
never done so well what jobs are these
people getting what is hen because the
traditional job we're and I don't say
this nastily but just for purpose of the
fellow goes and builds engines and the
wife goes and works in a store and they
just have enough money so they can start
to pay the rent and they could start to
put a family together and they could
start to pay for shoes for the kid
because you've got a traditional job
you're building
you got additional job you're selling
dresses or you're selling shoes they're
all going and I don't know what the jobs
are that are coming for these folks
because you can't put a family life
together on zero hour contracts if you
don't know what the supermarket although
all the DIY journeys gonna need you that
is the picture so if this is a way and
I'm not going to be as deep into it
because I know you're far speedier on on
new technology and this than I would
ever be if this is the way good because
traditional job and I don't think many
have woken up to this the change in the
way people work and the jobs they do is
seismic ya know so Michelle can I ask if
this clip these clicks and mortar
pop-ups are going to be activated you
only have enough and you go in and
there's not going to be sales assistants
how are they going to employ people I
think they're gonna work well I think
what's happening is and we all sit here
and we move over the decline of the high
street and talk about how awful it is
that people are losing their jobs and
absolutely is awful but then as
consumers when we finished that debate
we then go off and go on Amazon I just
want to come in here and say I'm very
concerned Amazon have just purchased
Whole Foods Amazon is a huge huge player
in the market and what I'm very
concerned about is effectively we're
surrendering everything to big tech US
firms now whether that's the search and
advertising industry which is killing
off newspapers and Google whether it's
Amazon and online shopping which started
with books but then pretty much like
tentacles expanded everywhere these
stores you're right there will be no
staff there it will be automated and I'm
very worried that actually instead of
this diversify in our house high street
it's going to minaton eyes our high
street you'll only end up with Amazon
stores Apple stores Google stores
because they are the big US Starbucks
and they don't pay their fair share tax
revenue I think these big firms should
be broken up it's about communities the
high-speed is actually about community
communities are going to be wrecked I
think this is just a massive PR exercise
from Amazon to stem the rising tide of
criticism about the tax that we don't
think they're paying I just got some
figures of the tax that there in the UK
in 2007
on sales of 11 billion they paint just
4.6 million quid in tax I mean that's
astonishing and I think and Dugger who
Amazon but who says we pay what we have
to pay and that's the killer line isn't
it
let's just hear what he has to say
because he's justifying what our husband
is doing it's often presented that
online and offline are in conflict and
we don't really see it that way
in our experience customers want what
they've always wanted which is fantastic
products and there are some fantastic
products here in this store today they
want fair prices and they want a
convenient service you know he's just
trying to justify what Amazon are doing
he's trying to say that you know they
work hand in hand shops I know they
don't because companies like his coming
rec the high street and I think and when
I talked about communities it is not
just about going to buy your clothes
it's about coffee shops and that would
go into a physical like shopping with
people yes but people also and the
pretends they go over there so it's such
a shame about the job losses but then
they click and Collect
and you pick up because it's do you get
a lot of your clothing from sent by
Amazon and other companies Amazon but I
very rarely going to the shops about the
environment so that's a driving off it
doesn't cardboard boxes to you you then
try them on you have every right you
don't like any of them so then he's got
to come back pay more petrol and diesel
in the white van take up road space to
take your dresses away yeah no I think
all right I went into a shop yesterday I
think part of the problem is business
rates are really high yeah and the grout
the Giants you pay very little tax so
the dice are really stacked against the
small independence we've already seen
the high streets taken over by chains
who can afford the business rates
because they got they can scale it up
we're seeing a return to independence
which is interesting because I think
shoppers people are shopping more
intelligently now people are whole eco
thing going on the shop I went into
yesterday would never seen before on our
the high street near me I walked in and
everything was in glass jars it was zero
waste zero
kuroh diamond met trick and all the rest
of it a shopping has to change if we're
going to keep the high streets at all
and that's going to mean less waste less
less deliveries for it to each household
less online shopping and I think it's
got to be consumer led you know we can't
all be having the great rocks is
arriving in it in a way to your point
and I'd know new world you can't really
celebrate the idea that government steps
in because companies are two successful
breaks elaborate so you take Facebook
exactly what most people don't realize
is Facebook owns whatsapp and Instagram
they acquired them and after they did
acquire them so the co-founder of
Facebook we said we wrote a very good
column for the New York Times
arguing himself that they should be
broken up and and and what happened and
he laid his case out was a very strong
case that after Facebook acquired what's
happened Instagram if you recall there
was a time where in social media app
world there were innovations on a
regular basis once Facebook acquired
these companies the innovations
completely stopped because actually the
angel investors realized there's no
point investing in these startups
Facebook's is gonna buy them out anyway
and then the founders take all that
money from facebook but the actual
innovation doesn't go anywhere so
they're smothering the market the same
happen with Google when it acquired
YouTube and now as a result you've got
advertising Google has a pretty much as
of dominance in the advertising killing
off newspapers especially with local
newspapers that's a difficult question
that's possibly the co-founder of
Facebook suggested that whatsapp as a
messaging service is separated from
Facebook as a social social media album
what that would do again is it brings
composition back into the market right
now there is no competition but I think
you just described it you described a
time of probably 3040 years going
everything since last year's
it's a nice thing to do I think and I
think it's it's a nice you know when
shops close people no longer go into the
town or the village or they they stay
away I think that's I think the death of
that is is every bit as important as the
loss of of retailers on the house
[Music]
there's just time for this the 6th of
June the 75th anniversary
the d-day landings an event that began
the liberation of Europe and was
undoubtedly one of the most significant
turning points during the Second World
War there's been numerous events to mark
the anniversary this week but one in
particular that's touched our hearts
take a look at it
[Music]
[Applause]
[Applause]
94 year old veteran John Hutten who
served in the 13th parachute battalion
made a tandem parachute jump to mark the
occasion for that John Hutten sir for
your service for bravery for jumping out
of a plane at the age of 94 for your
comrades as well you are our heroes for
a generation
Rachel quite an extraordinary thing to
do that generation men and women who
sacrificed their lives or risk their
lives to the country and to save Europe
all so modest when you get on the radio
they just try to interview the papers
the thing that we when I read this today
the thing that worried the most wasn't
getting hurt it was that the job will be
canceled for some great believers in a
united Europe generation to this week
but you can join in the debate by
searching for the pledge and the page is
now download as a podcast from iTunes so
you can listen thanks for watching we'll
see you next time